hello everyone welcome I my name is
Stuart de q I'm the program director at
the Yale Center for business environment
and warm welcome to the 2012-2013 save
and sustainable venture prize speaker
series the talk will be broadcast for
everyone in the audience here on Yale
youtube so welcome to both our audience
here and to the audience online a little
bit about the saban prize the saban
prize and speaker series are organized
by the Yale Center for Business and the
environment and sponsored to the
generous support of the andrew save and
Family Foundation the same prize
supports students and faculty efforts to
start a sustainable for-profit business
through cash prizes totaling $25,000
this venture prize competition also
provides a quality feedback from
professional judges extensive mentoring
from faculty and opportunities for
participants to meet and pitch their
ideas to top venture capitalists and
leading industry professionals today in
the speaker series we are quite pleased
to welcome Paul salute the CEO of
harvest power as he shares his personal
journey as a serial entrepreneur
environmental entrepreneur in the
renewable organic waste industry for the
past 25 years Paul is the chief
executive officer of harvest power
canada limited end of harvest power
incorporated Paul has been a leader in
the organics industry for more than 25
years in 1982 he found in earth grow Inc
which grew to be the second largest
producer of compost based lawn and
garden products in North America Paul
graduated from Cornell University
College of Agricultural and life
sciences a little bit about harvest
pound harvest power seeks to create a
more sustainable future by helping
communities better manage and
beneficially reuse their organic waste
through production of renewable energy
and soils mulches and natural
fertilizers just as a quick reminder for
the audience here the applications for
the save and prize are due on march
twenty seconds so if you have
team make sure you submit them go to the
sea bay website find it online just by
searching for the yellow Center for
business in the environment please join
me in welcoming Paul salud to Yale into
the 2012-2013 save and sustainable
venture prod speaker series okay good
afternoon it's great to be here at Yale
Aaron thank you for the kind invitation
and asking me to come down and and share
part of my story and i'm quite excited
to be talking to a group of students
right now because i think you're about
to enter an incredibly interesting world
and it harkens back to when i was in
college i graduated 1980 making me kind
of an old guy here but imagine what it
was like graduating college in 1980 I
mean the United States was clearly the
hegemonic superpower like the world had
never seen we are on the verge of 20
years of unbelievable economic growth
and under Reagan and then Bush one and
then Clinton and it was just overall
from a timing standpoint it was a great
time to graduate and a great time to
enter the workforce and so I think today
it's a whole lot different one of my
advisors has recently introduced me to
to a concept and it's called vuka and
i'm not sure if anybody here is familiar
with this acronym but it stands for
volatility uncertainty complexity and
ambiguity and I look at that and this
came out of military war planning in the
late 90s after we basically defeated the
Soviet Union and we had a very
simplistic world you're either with the
United States or you're with the Soviet
Union well after we basically defeated
won that battle in effect we went into a
whole totally different world and they
came up with this term and so I think
that's the world that graduates today
from from colleges and this is clearly a
you know one of the leading colleges
universities in the world that's the
world that you're going into so better
be armed for that and I also think
around a vuuka world that is the world
of an
entrepreneur if you're starting a
company you have volatility you have
uncertainty you have complexity and you
have ambiguity so from my standpoint
it's a world that I've been living in
because that's the world of a start-up
entrepreneur of an early stage company
now I have a larger company that I'm
managing so there's less of that sort of
buca in my day-to-day but then you have
the larger issues to deal with on behalf
of running a larger organization so I
also wanted to talk and I was struck
recently by a book I read and if I can
reference a Harvard professor at Yale
please forgive me but clay Christensen
he's a leading HBS professor and he
wrote a book how to measure one's life
and he was struck by as a Rhodes Scholar
at the HBS graduate he spent a lot of
work in innovation but as he went back
to his reunions five years everything's
great ten years certain people have
issues 20 years divorce alienation from
their kids career and Happiness a subset
not everybody 30 years more divorce more
disassociation or disconnection with
their children and certain people were
in jail and so he basically said and
this was out of an HBS and Andros
scholar program so we asked a question
why why is this happening I mean you
graduate from college you're full of all
this great optimism you're ready to go
out in the world you've got a great
education from a world-class University
and what he focused on was the sense of
purpose in one's life that at this stage
in your life it really is important to
really think deeply about your purpose
what you want to accomplish your values
and then try to match that to the bit to
the greatest degree possible with who
you go to work for whether it's a
government whether it's an NGO whether
it's a corporation and I think that that
is a really important point that I want
to leave with everybody here if there's
one nugget out of my talk i'll leave
that as the nugget because as I look
back now having been in business 30
years and I
have a sense of purpose of what I've
accomplished in my life and I think it's
directly tied to the decisions I made
coming out of college so with that we'll
get into my journey so I wanted to make
a connection with Yale and as you can
see I'm playing against this gentleman
Larry Ziggler le never seen Larry since
this was a photo taken in 1980 in ithaca
new york and as I look at that I say
geez what a mismatch what am I looking
to pass it into the low post for it
should be taking it to the basket but
regardless of that i put basketball up
there because that was my passion coming
out of cornell and that's what i wanted
to pursue i wasn't that great a player
and Cornell was not decorated team but
for me it was always very important that
that what i want to do i have to be
really passionate about that and i think
it's a trait that a lot of
entrepreneurial folks app and in this
case it served me well i had a couple
really good job offers turn them down
told my parents i want to play
professional basketball and after having
them watch me for four years and i'm not
i was not any kind of a star player they
had some appropriate questions about
whether i'm pursuing the right career I
went to a trial camp in Saint Peter's
College in jersey city three days three
days of three games in a row and at the
end of it I had a job offer to go play
basketball in Argentina and so typical
American relatively ignorant of the
globe had to go and find out okay it's
in South America and all that and two
weeks later I'm flying down to Argentina
and this was really this was a great
adventure and I was excited about it big
going away party and I'm going off to
play basketball in South America so got
there turns out that it's a big step
down from certainly ivy league
basketball I ended up having an
apartment to stay a restaurant to eat in
a couple thousand dollars of spending
money a month so to put it into
perspective the farthest thing
imaginable from what you think a
professional athlete today is all about
and
three weeks in we had no trainers there
was no tape and I had a bad left ankle
blew out my ankle so there I'm in the
hospital taking the x-ray the general
managers talking to the doctor in
Spanish and I was not fluent in Spanish
at that time and in so many words they
said the guy's got a bad ankle get rid
of him so I'm fired terminated three
weeks into my into my job and and that
was really it was like that what do i do
I was able to network with the other
Americans down there I was able to get
in another team the guy the American on
that team they just gotten rid of their
American because he couldn't play and I
was able to take that because they did
not have to invest a plane ticket to
bring someone else down so again put
this into perspective so I got got on
that team he had three cases of inch and
a half Johnson & Johnson athletic tape
learned how to tape my own ankles and
everything worked out great finish the
season played for a year in season and
Italy played for a season in in Belgium
I was on my way to Australia and that's
where I was going to play next and you
know I was like on this this wonder less
so on my way to to Australia came home
and my family has a large agribusiness
in Lebanon Connecticut my brother Mark
owns it and runs it now prides corner
farms were one of the largest growers of
ornamental horticultural plants on the
East Coast so got with my father and I
was telling him my plans of going to
Australia and he said well Paul there
might be an opportunity here and there
was a large mushroom farm and they had
all his spent mushroom compost that was
a huge waste product and was piling up
around eastern connecticut and they
needed a solution so I was familiar from
our nursery of like building great soils
to grow plants on so the idea of
composting and taking these organic
materials and converting them into
something that can grow plants was
something that that I was familiar with
so one thing one thing led to the other
and we basically started earth grow and
that's a picture of my younger brother
Tim and yes he did have a pair of pants
on but we are trying to try to early on
in this notion of natural organic
and so that and are also early on in
commercial composting because Ben again
back in the early to mid 80s composting
was not considered a industry is not
considered a profession it really was
considered like what what do you you
know people didn't even understand what
you're trying to do so we were part of
the first group that really
commercialized composting made it into a
business in taking these organic waste
products and converting them into great
fertilizers and soils and other things
to help make plants grow and from there
in Lebanon about an hour from New Haven
it's actually a fairly agricultural part
of Connecticut there are more chickens
in Lebanon Franklin and Basra than there
are people in the state of Connecticut
so there was this huge chicken manure
problem and that again was a challenge I
looked at that and after we figured out
how to turn the mushroom compost into a
great product we tackle chicken manure
next and really high an ammonia really
pasty smells I mean it is like the
nastiest possible material to work with
so I went on a global search to
understand how to process this material
and I came upon a system in Japan where
their big crop is rice grown underwater
so therefore they have to have a lot of
on-farm composting systems I saw what I
thought would work but it was very
rickety it was more of an on-farm versus
industrial scale came back with that
concept went to a manufacturing firm
that builds machines and then we put a
lot of process control and built this
into an industrial composting system
called the IPS systems and we started a
company called international process
systems so that really was an
opportunity to take this material and
turn it and after 21 days it would come
out looking like literally starbucks
coffee grounds I mean just beautiful
material and again we had more inventory
to sell and we are on to two great
things and then what happened they have
the 1991 ban on the disposal of
biosolids sewage sludge in the ocean
this is before your time at before 1991
literally all the sewage just went
untreated into the ocean so if you're a
coastal community you didn't have to
have necessarily a bio solids removal
program you
just dump it right into the ocean and
that was legal so at that point when
those regulatory bands kicked in we had
about the only north american or US
based system that was cost-effective and
worked everything else was these
massively complicated systems from
Europe so we started this company and
from roots from chicken manure right now
that's owned by Siemens and it's in wide
scale operation throughout the world
basically converting bio solids into a
high quality compost from the origins of
starting it up in Lebanon Connecticut so
16 years building earth grow when we
ended up building this technology which
I patented my father at that time was
still in the business he wanted to get
some chips off the table he was slowing
down we ended up selling that business
too Wheelabrator waste management they
subsequently sold it to Siemens stayed
on with earth grow filter with my
brother Tim and then Scots came knocking
the big national player and we ended up
selling that company to scotts in 1998
and I think what I learned during that
phase of my career is that
entrepreneurial management has a limit
and entrepreneurs are great you know
from the standpoint of their energy
their passion you know their willingness
to work all kinds of crazy hours their
commitment for their idea you know it's
so important to them but what can happen
is that you crowd out the team you
become a suffocating presence on the
company and you're not able to build a
team and manage a company in a more
professional way if you're going to
scale a business because an entrepreneur
is only one person or you maybe have
another entrepreneur as a co-partner you
only can do so much by definition and
ultimately if you're going to scale an
organization you need to build a team
and so I've incorporated that learning
into what I'm doing it at harvest power
right now so what happened 16 years at
earth grow some good success helped
pioneer commercial composting in the
United States and North America did not
know what I was going to do next and one
of the things that you find out in life
and you have these points where all of a
sudden you're free it's a great
opportunity and people will seek you out
if they know you've got a
track record of doing good work and
that's something I've seen in my career
time and again and so what happened an
associate that I had done business with
at earth grow I had recently taken over
as CEO of synagro was a small
money-losing company based in Houston
Texas it was doing about 20 million in
sales and losing about 5 million a year
and it was public so clearly was a in
need of a big turnaround so this
gentleman Ross patent called me and said
Paula need help and so at that point I
started to do some consulting it led
into chief chief operating officer and
president and what we did was synagro is
we took all of the biosolids and there's
about fifteen or sixteen thousand
publicly owned treatment works in the
United States they generate to materials
clean water for discharge and the solids
called bio solids and so we basically
executed a consolidation strategy and
organic growth and built that company to
about 350 million over 60 million of
cash flow and then ultimately it was
sold to a big private equity company and
it was from that point a big success
since then they've had some issues but
what I what I really you know learned
about that is that I learned the power
of anaerobic digestion which is a
centerpiece to what I'm doing now in
harvest power and I I really felt that
there was a big platform here at synagro
Board of Directors not ready to pursue
it that's one of the reasons why I left
after five years and I and I think that
that stayed with me that idea that I
developed and wanted to pursue in a
larger platform that's integral and that
and those thinking's and learnings have
all been incorporated into what I'm
doing now with harvest power but this
just shows you know what happens and so
Connecticut there's not a lot of land to
do land application but throughout the
country wheel and applied we composted
we actually made pellets and then sold
fertilizer pellets with a strong
emphasis around round beneficial reuse
of the bile salts so when I when I left
synagro like 2004-2005 one of the
projects I did my last project at
synagro was we built an inner
public digester in Southern California
right and that was around the time when
they had this California energy crisis
again just probably before your time but
literally you'd be driving along and the
traffic lights would stop they wouldn't
work I mean this is California you don't
expect this kind of third world type of
issues in a state like California but it
really was like wow there's a real
problem here and so from there that got
me all into the renewable energy space
and the importance of that and then
obviously the importance around climate
change and developing carbon-free energy
so I got I got very influenced by a
group that had been doing work on that
they approached me we got together we
formed this company environmental credit
corp and that was in the day when there
was a voluntary market through the
Chicago climate exchange and the lack
now federal policy that pretty much is
dead now we're riding on a b32 the
California cap-and-trade program which
thank God California is leading on that
but this is all about basically making
carbon-free energy bundling the carbon
credit the carbon that is not going the
atmosphere into a metric ton equivalent
and then trading that to a producer of
fossil fuel so you have an offset right
and if you look at cap and trade and the
success in the 1991 clean air act cap
and trade developing a market was really
i think proven to be the most successful
way of dealing with this but
unfortunately due to federal policy that
is this this company was before its time
but we financed it with a large
investment with a european company this
was before that people realized now that
the federal government is not going to
act on on climate change maybe it'll
change now under obama but so a large
large equity investment came in i was
chairman of that company put the
management team and we were really one
of the leaders in this space and and
they got so excited they said they put a
tender offer out for everybody but
management it was an all or nothing even
though i was really excited about the
company i said well i just think at that
point i sold my shares and sold my
shares a year later boom
it was like almost like the equivalent
of the dot-com and and the lesson on
that is that I would have stayed in but
it was something that I just decided to
do and sometimes you get lucky and I
have to put that up just pure luck I was
in the right place at the right time
fortunately made the right decision
company is still in business and I think
the California program is keeping the
carbon credit you know industry that's a
tiny industry alive right now and I'm
thankful for California's leadership but
long term I think this is a proven way
to deal with carbon emissions so from
there I got involved with an aquaculture
venture and I understand Aaron is a is a
is a fan of aquaculture and a Cornell
professor had a very compelling talk
about this whole trend here how wild
capture is flat last source of protein
we hunt for we don't hunt for chickens
or turkeys or cows or pigs but we hunt
for fish clearly it's flat lining and
maybe even going down so if you're going
to eat the same amount of that protein
you need aquaculture the trend line is
like you know irrefutable so he had
developed a recirculating system to grow
tilapia and so I put a group together we
made the investment turned out that the
lab scale to commercial scale there were
some engineering issues and the
professor had not really worked it all
out so jumped in tried to help out ran
the company stabilized it but then it
was up next to ithaca new york i live in
the boston area it was just too much and
so lessons learned on that one is
basically make sure when you jump into
something you you really understand it
that's my one failure I stayed on and
ran it for one year I left and I think
in 2006 went subsequently bankrupt and I
think 2009-2010 but it was a great
learning experience and I think the less
than this one to you learn from your
failures I think better than your
successes and in this recirculating
system that we were operating we
basically you had to take the water out
of the tanks where the fish were
swimming get rid of the ammonia nitrogen
and get rid of the co2 so we had all of
this warm co2 Laden
being exhausted from this facility 52
weeks a year and I said that's crazy i
mean that's like a source of energy and
of course co2 is going to help plants
grow so that led me from my next
business to start backyard farms and
backyard farms is is a the largest
producer of year-round tomatoes on the
East Coast we have 42 acres of
state-of-the-art greenhouses in Madison
Maine and that's a picture of my three
partners Wayne Davis re von der giessen
one of the great really greenhouse
growers in the world and then the mayor
Norman Dean of Madison Maine and has
anybody here from me well Maine is a me
as a special state it really is and you
know you remember main from the
coastline and all that's beautiful but
you go north of Augusta and Maine is
like Appalachia it's rural rural America
so this this town led by Norman had a
had a business gateway park for seven
years a they met monthly and they were
trying to attract industry into their
town they didn't sell one lot they had
like 27 lots in those seven years we
show up and said we'd like to grow
tomatoes you know in your town and the
reason why we attracted to Madison they
had their own electric company so if you
look at your electric bill it's the cost
of the electricity and the transmission
and it's about 5050 so we were able to
then work with Madison electric drive
our transmission cause down to a
fraction of a penny and then you're
buying electricity and about a thirty to
forty percent of Maine's electricity's
hydro so it's a good clean source of
electricity so we went to Madison worked
a deal out with the town bought a big
farm on the Kennebec River in built
backyard farms and what we did with our
analysis was that we've said the minimum
size greenhouse to make it
cost-effective was 25 acres and we drew
inspiration from the greenhouse industry
in holland which is significant but you
talked to the typical americans and say
you want to build a 25-acre greenhouse
they think you're crazy that's just
beyond the scale once you start with one
acre but the idea was we wanted to
produce local food state-of-the-art
Oh lights all the things that allow you
to grow year round in the wintertime and
then be a year-round producer of local
foods and that's what we did so again
the modern Dutch venlo greenhouse you
can see the grow lights on their
significant electricity but because we
had a very good electricity rate that's
why we attracted in that's why we went
to Madison and when you basically put
those lights on and it's dark I mean
literally almost have to put sunglasses
on I mean it's amazing those lights are
teed to go and what they call the par
light spectrum which of the
photosynthetic DAC of radiation for to
700 nanometers and then you could tune
in the light spectrum and it would grow
as if it was the Sun it was just it's
amazing what grow lights can do
pollinated everything with bumblebees
and as you can see in the top right the
plants they were in indeterminate
variety meaning they were a vine variety
of tomatoes so every 12 inches you would
have a fruit set and so what would
happen is that you'd pick the
low-hanging fruit and then you drop the
vine one foot and then the top of it
would grow one foot in that same week
and you have a new flower set so it was
about an 8-foot vine and the most mature
ripe tomatoes were at the bottom and
then the flower sets like in the bottom
right here we're at the top and so is
really a clever design and so the
business proposition is Tomatoes that
were actually ripened on the vine could
be picked and delivered to New England
and New York groceries in the same day
and it has been a tremendous success
we've expanded now it's at 42 acres I
company found it ran it as CEO for up I
think three years stayed on the board
and then I left but it's basically I
think a very very successful story 400
people up in central Maine growing
tomatoes and making a profit so this
leads me to the to the present this
leads me to what I'm doing now and it's
been great to be able to draw lessons
learned inspiration from everything I've
done in my career and I I got together
with a leading you know VC my founding
investors kleiner
guns there there an active green tech
investor and really just a unbelievably
great group to work with and from there
I had a friend who was one of their I
just joined them as one of their their
green tech partners and this is a lesson
learned this this gentleman who now's on
my board of directors his name is Amal
deshpande his father worked with me at
synagro was one of my best engineers I
relied on him for everything became good
friends got to know the family got to
know Amal influenced him he ended up
going to the Cornell Johnson business
school he worked with me at finger lakes
aquaculture while he was there then took
a job at cargill ventures and it was
recruited by kleiner perkins and his is
there one of their green tech partners
now so that basically when I went out to
see them all this was after i left
backyard farms and we talked about
what's next and the majority of what
I've done is around the management of
organic waste with a focus on the
beneficial Reeves and so we drew
inspiration on what's what was going on
in Germany and Europe at that time where
they built you know a multi-billion
dollar green tech industry around
anaerobic digestion so we knew that the
technology was there and we we knew that
there was good separation of green waste
out there's a about sixty percent of
leaves grass and brush is recycled in
the United States still the balances is
ending up in a landfill but in food
waste about ninety-five percent ends up
in a landfill so I don't know what Yale
does but we'd love to be able to work
with with your food waste and so there's
some follow-up after my top and but food
waste for the most part is not separated
it's mixed in with the garbage and it's
disposed of and if you look at the EPA
pie chart there's about 30 million tons
of green waste leaves grass and brush
there's about 30 million tons of food
waste there's about 15 20 million tons
of wood so upwards of 80 million tons of
organics that for the most part with
food anyway are ending up in a landfill
and we think that is a tremendous
opportunity so we had a focus on
maximizing the value this is a picture
of one of our our sites and get into a
little bit more detail about how we how
we do things
but as part of the as part of the
thinking about why why we started why we
started harvest power what was the
reason why a new company had to get
started in this area and the way we
looked at it there were three basically
intersecting challenges that the harvest
power business model addressed first one
is well understood except for members
maybe of the Republican Party is that
basically we've got rising co2 and this
is the Noah's Manalo observatory and
what I love about the spike tooth can
anybody I'm sure this crowd knows why
there's a spike to thunder yeah
photosynthesis so photosynthesis is is
an unbelievably effective way to
obviously remove co2 out of the
atmosphere so you see when the spring
summer fall high rate growth more
sequestering of co2 and in the inverse
of that less growth in less sequestering
of co2 so I think it's refute able we're
seeing this we're seeing the impact on
climate change we need to have
carbon-free energy that's something I
believe strongly in and I wanted to be
part part of that the other other issue
we have is is landfills so you look at
landfills it's still the dominant method
of disposal in the United States oh I
think over sixty percent goes to
landfills still we do a lot of recycling
there's composting but landfills really
are the backbone of the waste disposal
system right now in the United States so
what we see here there's a declining
number of them clearly some of them are
bigger but there's a declining number
and they're hard to cite and so they're
easy to cite if you do long-haul
transportation but that means there's
transportation costs so we looked at
that trend and we like that as well also
we like this trend there's a increase in
disposal fees and tipping fees with
landfills because ultimately if we're
going to have a successful business
model we needed to compete with the
existing market structure that's out
there right now so we like the fact that
landfill tipping fees are going up and
then lastly because anaerobic digestion
in composting that's really our
technology
platform the nitrogen phosphorus
potassium micronutrients are still in
the residual product you don't lose them
you don't destroy them so the great
opportunity we saw here and we have huge
operations in California probably the
largest marketer of compost to the AG AG
lands in the Central Valley and if you
see the input costs fertilizer NPK
rising petroleum prices rising mineral
prices and then you see crop prices is a
disconnect so the ability to take these
organic materials high organic matter
stabilized organic matter benefit the
soil so you don't need to water as much
you've got that organic matter in there
plus all the benefits of the NPK and
micronutrients we like that trend as
well so those intersecting trends
basically was we're incorporated into
into harvest business model and so can
you look at harvest and say do we have
you know some world beater technology
advantage I would say no what harvest
has it has a fundamentally sound
business model and I think that has been
lacking in cleantech and if we had just
gone in this current environment of
three dollar mm BTU natural gas due to
fracking if we had just been a pure-play
renewable energy company I probably
wouldn't be standing here right now we
might not even be in business so I think
you have to in the environment now this
Renaissance the fossil fuels in the
United States and North America you need
to have multiple revenue sources if
you're a clean tech company like a
harvest to be sustainable so for us
organics processing and collection
biogas and producing renewable energy
and marketing the end product the sum
total of that revenue gives us a
competitive advantage and allows us to
attract the organic waste that
ordinarily would be going to a landfill
so i can't go to a customer and say you
know it's all going to landfill we all
know that that's not good right now
here's what it's going to cost you and
if it's more than their bearing right
now i will probably won't get a second
meeting and that's just the reality of
the marketplace so for us extracting the
maximum value out of these organic
substrates these organic waste is fun
too
until to our business and the reason why
we be able to grow so a little bit on
harvest actually this is one of our
energy gardens in the upper right it's
in operation right now but we're
managing now about two million tons
throughout North America leaves grass
brush also food waste some manure
operate 30 facilities were at over 100
million in revenue close to 450 500
employees we've got now the energy story
is coming on we're starting up two of
our anaerobic digesters right now the
third one will be started up by the end
of this year and we really are building
a new model and if you look at like what
we're doing we're a leader in North
America you compare that to Germany gin
how many anaerobic digesters they built
last year over 1,000 so it just puts it
into perspective or a leader but we're
gonna we're going to demonstrate it but
we're still not even close to
approaching the scale of the opportunity
here Germany I'll get into that there
was some policy reasons but nevertheless
and I've been able to attract some some
great investors very grateful for the
support that I've been able to attract
and I think the ability to execute in a
business model and show that you know
you can make money on a unique business
model is directly tied to being able to
attract additional capital as well so a
little little side way into into Germany
I mean what Germany has done is just
nothing short of spectacular very much
policy driven now we don't have that
policy in this country right now and
I've generally found tracking
environmental regulations we are about
10 years behind Northern Europe you know
so what they start will eventually get
there but it's just unbelievable right
over 7,000 biogas 17 terawatt hours of
electricity energy needs for over 5
million households and one thing that I
think I want to distress that most
people understand because when you talk
about renewable energy what do people
talk about wind and solar now Germany
has the number one photovoltaic
installed base in the world they've got
the fourth largest wind installed base
in the world and if you add up the
energy from organics in
Germany which are both anaerobic
digesters and wood chip burning plants
you have to take the energy from wind
and solar combined x 3 and you still
don't get the energy from organics in
Germany so it's kind of like a little
bit of the Rodney Dangerfield we just
don't get their respect of the wind and
solar now in addition you have
intermittency issues with wind and solar
wind has to be blowing son has to be
shining sure everyone is familiar with
capacity factor they're both in the 20s
so that's not really reliable power if
you look at biogas our facilities are
operating 24 7 365 we have to take them
down to do maintenance on the engine
gensets but our capacity factors are
over ninety-five percent so you have
base load power and that is what the
utilities really want because when
you're buying intermittent power like
that they really can't take off the
peaker plants and the other parts of
their electric grid that really should
be replaced right so I think Germany is
a great great inspiration i think is a
model and you just have to look at it in
addition to the separation of all
organic programs and the band from one
process organic waste in landfills they
had something called the feed-in tariff
and in fact they socialized the cost I
know it's a bad term in the United
States but they socialized the cost of
renewable energy they said listen if
investors looking to get a ten percent
return on their capital what is the
electricity price they need from
photovoltaics from wind and from biomass
and they allowed that price to be met
and guess what happened capital flowed a
multi-billion dollar industry was
created and so again this was a
reflection of the German taxpayer
because they financed that but what's
happened is that they have built a
multi-billion dollar industry with tens
of thousands of jobs and it's an
industry that's not going away so it's
great inspiration we're not there yet in
the United States but I hope at some
point we can get there if we had taken
the German model I mean our economy is
about from a GDP standpoint is about
four times the size of Germany from an
agricultural standpoint it's probably
eight times the size of Germany
so I mean there's a potential here for a
multi multi-billion dollar industry
around us in the United States and here
I'm standing up in front of you saying
that we're building our third plan and
we're considered the leader so I just
want to put it into perspective there's
a long way to go but i think that the
good news is with the size of our
economy and the opportunity that's out
there we will get there here's a picture
of our high solids anaerobic digestion
plant built a tower Richmond British
Columbia facility a lot of communities
they do what they call source separation
of organics so you'll have a green bin
so green waste will go in there and food
waste will go in there so it's really
it's not a pumpable substrate it's
really something you need to move with a
front end loader so we have this
facility is an operation right now
producing about three megawatts of
combined heat and power and from there
we put it into our tunnels we percolate
extract the organic acids and then
convert that into biogas and then after
about 15 days and our tunnels we finish
the material with a shorter composting
process so then the NBN products here
our compost and energy and the inputs
are organic waste vector that goes into
the facility so this the largest high
solids ad facility right now operating
in North America here's a plant that we
took this in the fall basically this
this plane now is finished this is in
biological commissioning right now this
plant is in outside of Toronto in London
Ontario so the reason why we're us-based
company but we operate well in Canada
and Canada has great policy I mean we've
been able to get long-term good Power
Purchase Agreements there's a lot of
organic waste food processing in the
ontario area and this is a what they
call a low solids anaerobic digestion
system so we're using a technology
called complete stirred tank reactor we
take in a variety of strictly food
processing way similar to the scrapings
off your plate it gets slurried and then
gets pumped into this tank we break down
the organics and this plant is about six
to six and a half megawatts of combined
heat and power and then after 25 days in
the digester we then D water and then
the solids then are dried with the
combined heat and power engine gents
that we have into a fertilizer pellet
which we then market so again organic
waste coming in the front door and then
what comes out is basically about 5,000
tons of fertilizer pellets and energy
and then the the scent rate that comes
off the dewatering we basically have a
deal with the town that goes into the
sewer system of the town they process it
and ultimately responsible for the
discharge and they add capacity at their
wastewater treatment plant so it worked
out well this is a this is our latest
plant this will be operating the end of
this year and all three of our first
plants are really different and they all
attract different niches this one is
built at a large theme park in central
florida in the orlando area and we're
taking all of the organic waste from
this theme park and other theme parks as
well which consists of basically source
separated organics food waste and then
we also are mixing then the thickened
waste activated sludge otherwise known
as bio solids from their wastewater
treatment plant so that's code digestion
the bio solids with the food waste and
we're locating right next to the
wastewater treatment plant so what this
allows then is that we take in the bio
solids we already take in the food waste
we Co digest and then from there similar
to the London plant 25 days of basically
retention time in the tanks and then
from there we D water that scent rate
goes back to the front head works of the
wastewater treatment plant and then that
that solids is dried with the combined
heat and power engine genset into a
fertilizer pellet which we market that
so the power that we're generating from
the organic waste generated just from
the steam park is double the power of
the 20
gallon per day wastewater treatment
plant so wastewater treatment is a
really good off taker for us because its
base load wastewater treatment has to
run 24 7 365 so we're taking all that
organic waste and getting and they're
getting double the power they're buying
the power back and that'll be the first
true green waste water treatment plant
in North America so to kind of kind of
summarize I've gone through like 30
years here in about I know half an hour
or so so just have a few kind of summary
slides that that I wanted to share with
everybody and what one of them is is
around you know what are the key lessons
learn right we talked about the volatile
uncertain complex ambiguous world you're
all graduating into good luck right and
carefully think about the purpose and
your values and try to match those and i
know we have I think a fairly socially
conscious crap but there's nothing wrong
with the private sector I've made a
living in the private sector I've made a
good living and but one of the things
that that I think I served me well is
I've only taken an opportunity that I
was absolutely passionate about I think
that's really important I know some of
you might have loans and that might
dictate you know the kind of job you get
in the kind of income but to sacrifice
because something you really believe in
it has served me quite well and if
there's one thing I want to leave with
you it's that few more slides my
curiosity is as served me enormously
well and I really urge you to stay
curious that is like such such an
important trait to have if you look at
like what I've done everything I've done
I is I've been curious about I've been
passionate about I pursued it you have
lessons learned it leads you to new
opportunities it's something that is
really a hugely important trait and you
know there's certainly nobody more
curious than than our friend mr.
Einstein and also i mean the notion of
mentors i mean i was very fortunate my
mentor at an early stage was my father
right i was very fortunate from that
Stan
point he was a really really important
mentor i have i've had other mentors
throughout my business career but the
importance of having a mentor somebody
who's going to check what you're saying
and somebody who you trust is going to
push back when appropriate I think is so
important the the whole idea of improved
and increasing self-awareness and the
only way you're going to get that is
when you have somebody that knows you
well enough and that you trust that
they're going to push back at you and
force you to think it through carefully
so I think it's not just having a mentor
and an early stage in life although very
important but it's having mentors
throughout your career I think that's
really really important and it's about
the team he's a he's one of my heroes
for sure Michael Jordan but as I
mentioned my challenges when I was first
starting out very much of an
entrepreneurial manager I can get it I
can do it I can do it better than
anybody else what but then what do I
have all these employees for so you take
the air out of the room it's not good it
works well at the start up at the early
stage but now with where I'm at with
harvest close to 500 employees I've got
a really skilled management team so how
do you want to be treated you want to be
micromanaged you want to have somebody
else do everything for you know you want
to be empowered you want to be able to
demonstrate your competency as a
professional and so me as a CEO now my
role is to work through my team and
that's something that as I have grown
and as I've learned and increase my self
awareness through mentoring basically
those are hugely important lessons and
so at the end of the day the only just
look at Michael Jordan right he was a
phenomenally probably the greatest
individual basketball player ever but
until Scottie Pippen and John Paxson and
other guys joined him and he trusted his
teammates that was when he was able to
go off and become the Michael Jordan
that we know winning six championships
and really going down as one of the
greatest greatest players ever so
ultimately an individual can't scale a
team can scale so it depends on your
aspirations in a company and there's
roles for the entrepreneurial manager
and that's why they call it the founder
problem right because oftentimes the
founder can't get out of his own way I
found it and let a bunch of companies
and then got to move the founder out of
the way and you got it you got to
basically bring in a manager manager
that can that can lead the company
through the team and it's the rare
founder like guys like Steve Jobs Bill
Gates Larry Ellison those are geniuses
that have been able to sort of
transition their career and understand
what it's like to be the entrepreneur
founder and what it's like to be a CEO
of a big big corporation this is my last
slide so one of the things I learned in
basketball is the sense of competition I
don't know I'm sure whether whether you
play Ultimate Frisbee or basketball
doesn't matter but I think you're going
to go into a very very volatile
uncertain complex and ambiguous world I
hope you're ready for the fight and I
hope some of the things I've shared here
today are helpful to you I wish you the
best of luck and I hope to engage in
some conversations here as the day goes
on so thank you very much
so time for questions thank you so much
for talking to us today I'm Lara
Burmeister and I worked on a project
last year we had the good fortune
Anthony have also worked on it and to
work with deep the Department of Energy
and Environmental Protection on their
waste infrastructure and how to move
forward and we dealt a lot with organics
and policy here and how much they
actually would really like to push that
and there was a project a few years ago
that ultimately didn't come through
because of the NIMBY situation where
they were you know essentially the
community was not willing to have a
composting site in there you know in
their area and so now they have a big
campaign trying to switch food waste
food scrap and trying to change the
public perception what is your feeling
when you sit like it's kind of a chicken
and egg situation like how do you see in
the state's what your main challenges
are of implementing these in states that
seem to have policies that are very Pro
anaerobic digestion priamos doing no
very good question and a lot of it deals
with the NIMBY not on my backyard right
and in certain communities it's banana
build absolutely nothing anywhere near
anybody and so when you're in the
Northeast and you're fairly you know
population dense it's all about finding
the right site and having community
support will never go into a community
and try to bulldoze our way and it just
doesn't work and so what you need to do
you need to demonstrate that you're good
operators you're not going to smell up
the community and that's all very
important one of the great things about
anaerobic digestion it's done in an
airtight gas-tight facility so those
volatile organics are broken down and
then literally they're combusted through
the combined heat and power engine
genset but to say oh this works in
germany and all that stuff and
everything we realized that you had to
build these and show demonstrated track
record of successful operation without
creating nuisances in the community
because if you do you're dead so that's
a really really important thing and
I think the good news is you can do that
but it involves good operation the right
technology because the policymakers here
in Connecticut Massachusetts California
other sort of leading progressive states
they get it so now it's more into
implementation mode and we're part of
those discussions and we'd love to you
know but we have significant operations
in Connecticut right now and around the
hartford area in fairfield so we're
looking for four sites in connecticut
right now and there's a lot of food
waste so I'm optimistic but it's not
going to be easy thank you very much my
name is Pedro Leona from Mexico Serena
I've worked on on the electric utilities
efforts to scale up boys to energy there
so I wanted to ask you about Germany
what what what policies did you see in
Germany that drove this scaling up of
this concept was it just the feed-in
tariffs or were there other sorts of
incentives like on tipping fees and and
about your your own customers from whom
you source the organic waste are they
also probably also regularly customers
for energy as well good question so
around Germany it's all policy but that
policy created a huge economies of scale
in an industry so the market responded
and what Germany did quite clever they
didn't make it on tipping fees they did
it on electricity sales so they
carefully calculated the policymakers
what does a photovoltaic farm a wind
farm or a biomass ad facility need in
the form of electricity price for you to
get a ten percent return on capital they
figure that out and that attracted huge
amount of capital and so as a result
these are all higher cost electricity
than burning coal or nuclear or anything
like that so what the German government
did is they said ok we're going to
socialize the cost of building out a
renewable energy industry and it worked
it really worked and it's very
I mean this is very controversial in
United States you mentioned socializing
the cost of renewable energy in our
current environment I just don't think
it's going to happen that's why we're
operating in North America that's why
there's higher rates in Canada and we're
excited about that and then around
sourcing organic waste and generating
energy and sending it back that's
exactly what we're doing with our
Central Florida plan we're getting in
that way shed from that one customer
we're getting other organic waste and
then we're selling it back to them to
run their wastewater treatment plant and
the excess power to offset their overall
power and we did that in Florida no rec
market no RPS standard in Florida and it
works because really the tipping fee the
disposal fee is the revenue that you
need to duplicate the feed-in tariff
model in Germany because you're in the
United States I mean we're selling a
power for seven cents in Florida so we
needed that revenue in the formula
disposal fees and collectively you have
enough to get a return on that project
but if it was without the tipping fees
and disposal fees coming in it wouldn't
work projects that way where you sell
the power back to the organic in Canada
we're selling to the grid pc hydro in
canada in british columbia we're selling
to their their grid and in in ontario
we're selling to Ontario Power Authority
so if you're able to get something from
the grid to meet your returns that's
great otherwise you know you can work
with a large generator
hi my name is jeff woodward on my second
year joint degree student between the
school of management in school forestry
um thank you so much for talking about
team and I'm actually wonder if you
could talk a little bit more about it
specifically in terms of when you're
starting an earlier stage venture how
you approach building a team and what
types of things you think about even at
a small small startup team is hugely
important and it even becomes more
important as an organization the tours
and I have a I have a working philosophy
around that and I think if a team is
going to be a functional team right I
think it there needs to be trust I mean
that is to me the underlying single most
important thing you know devoid of all
the issues with politics and all except
you need to just have a trust and early
stage smaller companies they can do that
well because you're working together so
closely you know when you have trust you
have the ability to debate things you
need to do that that is so important I'm
guilty sometimes of getting a head of
steam and it's like I'm absolutely right
well that's no one is right all the time
so you need to have people that are
willing to take you on and you need to
have that kind of constructive conflict
that's hugely important and and that's
something I've had to work on and
encourage with people that work with me
from there you have that you have that
conflict then you you commit on a
direction and everybody buys into it
you've got accountability and you get
results so to me you know that is sort
of the foundational element about how to
build a high functioning team and from a
standpoint of building a senior
leadership team the most important thing
is that if you follow what I just said
you will act in a cohesive manner and
then you can build the clarity in your
organization and everybody understands
what you're trying to do but it does
start from having a cohesive senior
leadership team
great all right thank you very much